Let's show some examples of equation solving.
You will see the equations in this video.
This will not require a lot of steps, but I really do
I want to focus on what is really happening on
Equation, and why it makes sense I follow the steps that
We do it.
This is the first equation here, we have - I will write it. (x = x in Arabic)
- Set to 11 equals 7
So this tells us - we have that little point here, let me
Clear, let me clear that point.
Do not you think I have some types of decimal numbers there.
There you go.
Let's go back to the problem now.
So, what does this mean?
This means that the total number to 11 equals 7.
And you are probably able to do this in your head.
Do you know, what should I add to the 11 to become 7?
If it is we will have some types
Negative numbers.
But we will learn how to solve this in an organized way.
So what do we want to do this, when we solve the equation
It should be on this formula, when we finish everything,
O Something worth.
That will be our answer.
We will know what figure this formula replaces.
Now, to bring it, we just want it to be put
The unknown x is in the left side of the equation.
We do not want this 11 there.
We want to get rid of 11 somehow, on the left side
Of the equation.
Now to do that, we can not just get rid of it just on
The left side
You probably want to say, wait, let me get 11 from
The left side of the equation.
But this is an equation!
Anything you do on an aspect of the equation has to do
On the other side of them.
If x is set to 11, it is equal to 7, x set to 11 from 11
It will not be worth 7 anymore.
You must also subtract 11 out of 7.
Now they are equal.
Remember, I really want to stress this.
I really want you to think about what
This means equality.
Equation, it comes from the concept of equality.
This is equal to this.
These two things are equal amounts.
Now, in order to be able to equality properly, anything I do
For this, if I put 11 of this quantity, in order
This equality is true, I must also ask 11
Of the quantity that is here. x plus 7 are equal.
If they are still equal after 11.
Now let's focus on the left side.
Negative 11 (-11) plus 11, negative 11 plus 11,
You will be tested, right?
11 minus 11 equals 0.
So you will have only the left side X equal
For 7 rails of 11.
Now what 7 - 11?
You can draw the line of numbers out, if you want.
If we draw the number line here - 0.1,2,3,4,5,6,7.
7 There.
And if we subtract 11 from that, you return back 1,2,3,4,
5,6,7,8,9,10,11.
8,9,10,11.
It takes you to -4.
7 - 11 = -4
This is our first equation.
Now we have 7 multiplied by a number - these
The new problem - 7 multiplied by X equals 21.
This X will be different from this
Who is here.
How, once again, did we bring it in the form in which X is equal
Something ?
Remember, we made X equal to Achi.
How do we form that body?
Let me rewrite the problem.
7 multiplied by equals 21.
Well, I can think of it in two ways.
If you divide 7 multiplied by X on 7, for what
I will get ?
If you divide it to 7, what will remain?
7 multiplied by a divider divided by 7, so only it will be
Something .
It will only end with X.
But if left on the left of
Equation, I must make it on the right side
Of the equation.
Remember, 7X equals 21.
It's the same as 21.
In order to make this equal to that when I divide 7 on
Left side, I must also I swear 7 on the right side.
When I do that, 7 multiplied by X divided by 7 - only that
Will equal X - and 21 divided by 7 equals 3.
If the solution for this equation is X = 3.
You can prove it.
Take 3, put it in the equation.
7 * 3 is already equal to 7.
Same thing up there.
Make X equal -4.
-4 + 11 Same as 11-4,
Already equal to 7.
Let's do this here.
This time it seems a bit tricky, but you
You'll see, it's not too bad.
If we have 5X on 12 equals 2 \ 3.
Now, how do you isolate the X here?
What can I multiply or divide to isolate?
Well, what if we want to hit both sides of these
Equation in 12 \ 5?
What will happen ?
So if we hit the left side with 12 \ 5 - f
Remember, anything I do on one side, must
I do it on the other side of the equation.
If you hit the left side by 12/5, you should
Hit the right side with 12/5 in order
The equivalence is correct.
But why did you want to choose 12/5?
Because I wanted to, I choose a number that completely cancels
5/12.
is not it ?
I've got 5 \ 12 here.
12 \ 5 multiplied by 5/12, the 12 canceled, the 5
Canceled, and you are now with the X only.
If X has been made equal to 2 \ 3 multiplied by 12 \ 5
You can divide 12 by 3 and have 4 output.
You can measure 3 on 3 and have 1 output.
If you can get 2 multiplied by 4 equals 8 \ 1
Multiplied by 5, which is 5.
If X is equal to 8/5.
Now maybe you say, wait, sit up, there you divided on 7,
Here you are struck by the inverse reflex.
How do I know what to do?
The answer is, you can do well.
I can do this exactly for the same problem that way.
I started with 7X equal to 21.
Instead of dividing by 7, how much I said, let me
Strike with the inverse reflection of the 7.
If I can, I can strike the opposite of the 7 on both sides
Of the equation.
This is equivalent to dividing by 7.
You can prove it.
When you hit 1/7, that's exactly the same when
Divide on 7.
If it does, these will be canceled.
This is 1/7.
The 7 are canceled.
X is equal to 21/7, which equals 3.
Similarly, there, I have 5X / 12.
Let me write it that way.
I can type it as 5 \ 12X, equal to 2/3.
This is exactly the same problem.
I just posted the X a little.
5 \ 12 multiplied by 5X \ 12.
Now here, I can only say, let me swear both parties on
The inverse inversion 5/12.
If I just could I swear by 5/12.
But what do I mean by I am 5/12 ??
That's the same thing when I hit a 12/5.
Division of the same factor when beating
With the inverse reflex.
If this is this, we've done the same thing.
Whether divided by laboratories, as we did here,
Or whether they are hit by a traverse reflex
For laboratories, you do exactly the same process.
Now let's do some of these other problems. and this is
Really only to introduce you I variable is not always X.
We can bee for Q
We can bee for Z.
We can bee for s.
We can bee for anything.
So let's solve this down here.
If we have - and will write - you have q less than 13
Equals -13.
If again, we want to isolate q.
We will be, q equals something.
Then we will solve our problem.
So how do we isolate q?
How can we get rid of these 13.
What if we add 13 to both sides of this equation?
If you add 13 for both parties in this equation
I add 13, because if I add 13 to -13, or
-13 Here, I will get 0.
If the left side of this equation becomes q.
And then what is the right side now?
So that will cancel.
And the right side -13.
+13, the result is 0.
If resolved, q is equal to 0.
We can check it out.
It is 13.
If this works.
Actually I've forgotten who I'm checking out here.
Let's check it out.
The fun thing about algebra, is that you can
Always check your answer.
We got an X equal to 8 \ 5 here.
Let's check our answer.
5 \ 12 multiplied by X multiplied by 8 \ 5 What equals ??
5 Canceled.
You can divide the 8 by 4 to get 2.
You can divide the 12 by 4 to get 3.
It is equal to 2/3.
If we can check.
That's a wonderful thing.
First answer your answer, you can always be sure, if you are
Have enough time, so I got the right answer.
Let's do the last two.
Our Z +1. Equal to 3.0001.
Again, we want to get rid of 1.1 on
The left side .
The best way to do this is that I can think of asking
1.1 from both sides, or add negative 1.1, anyway
You want to do it.
If you do it on the left side, I have to do the same thing on the right side.
Otherwise equality will not remain true.
If this is equal to this, so that both sides
Equally, anything I do on the left side must
I'm doing it right.
So let's see.
If 1.1 is introduced from Z + 1.1, these two are deleted, and
Only Z remains equal to 3.0001 - 1.1.
If here we will do a little
A tenth offer.
That's probably the hardest part of this problem.
If 3.0001 - 1.1.
You want to align decimal numbers.
1.1.
1.1.1.
Just keda costume.
And we can even add some zeros there, to make things clear.
And let's do the subtraction.
1-0 = 1.
0-0 = 0
Oh, we do not have, --- we can not say 0-1.
We can regroup or borrow.
If this becomes 10, which is 1.
We will take 1 from here, so
It becomes 2, right?
We borrowed from the 3, we recombine the numbers
We took the whole one and put it in the double digits, so I have
It becomes 10/10.
If 10 - 1 = 9.
We have our decimal point.
And then 2 -1 = 1.
If our answer is Z = 1.9001
We can check them.
What is z + 1.1 ??
Let's collect it.
You made 1,00,9.1 be 10.1 + 1 + 1 to be 3, we have
Our decimal point, we have brought 3.0001.
That's a good review to put the numbers down.
OK .
We have this last problem.
21S is equal to 3.
As we have said, we can do this in two ways, namely
Especially the same way.
21 * Some numbers = 3.
Well, what happens if we hit both
The sides b 1 \ 21?
B.
Inverse inversion only is the figure that arises from the introduction
Variable, so multiply variables.
Well, 1 \ 21 * 21 \ 1 = 1, if we made S equal
3/21.
The 3/21 itself is 1/7.
We can check them.
What is 21 * 1/7?
It's equal to 21/7.
21 \ 7.
Which is 3.
To achieve the main purpose, I can solve
This is the problem - instead of multiplying by 1 \ 21 -
let's see . 21S equals 3 - I could, instead of
Multiplication in 1 \ 21, the equation is completely something
Would like to divide only both sides on 21.
So these are deleted.
S has been made equal to 3/21 which is equal to 1/7.
Anyway, we hope you have found these examples useful to you. # (Translated by Dr. Sulaiman the Spectrum).